We're on a second. All in favor? Aye. Any opposed?
All right, that's 5-0.
I have 16C public hearing regarding the annexation of territory's own
C to the City of River Valley Landscape and Lighting Maintenance District
number 8-9-1, consolidated the district and the levy and collection of
assessments within such territory, southeast corner Rubido Boulevard and
El Rivino Road, Awamosa Commerce Park. Mr.
We have a staff report on this item. Thank you, Mayor, members of the City
Council, a resolution 2022-06 pertains to annexation to our existing
lighting and landscape district. As the process back in December of 2021,
City Council approved resolution initiating the annexation of the district
approved engineer report and set up a date for the public hearing.
Official ballot was mailed to the applicant and they expressed their
contracts with the proposed ballot. So staff is recommending approval of
resolution 2022-06, annexing the project within the Lighting and
Landscape District 89-01. With that, Ms. Mayor, I conclude my presentation
and happy to answer any questions you may have.
Thank you, Mr. Tour. Are there any questions from Council?
I will now open the public hearing.
Swascale, any comments? No public comments? I have none up here.
Being there, no public comments. I will now close the public hearing.
Ms. Swascale will you tabulate the ballots? Yes, I received one electronic ballot
from two owners. All those cast were in favor of the proposed assessment.
Thank you, Ms. Swascale.
Any questions, comments, discussion? All right, this is easy.
Can I have a motion and a second? Motion from Altimorano.
Second, Barajas-Bisbee. All in favor? Aye.
Opposed? All right, passes 5-0.
Item 17-B. Consideration of an interim urgency ordinance of the City Council of the City of
Group of Allie.